schwabach in mittelfranken
hier lebt christa hausladen sambale sie
ist 65 verwitwet und pflegebedürftig
seit einem schlaganfall vor vier jahren
braucht sie hilfe im alltag chris tat
glück ihre tochter tatjana ist 2017
deshalb zurück ins elternhaus gezogen
und noch besser die 35-jährige ist
examinierte altenpflegerin und pflegt
ihre mutter
also sie waren anfang wahnsinnig
körperlich eingeschränkte rechte seite
war vollständig gelähmt sie musste
künstlich ernährt werden und sie hatte
gar kein sprachvermögen mehr und mit
einer schier unendlichen kraft hat sie
sich nach diesem wirklich sehr ernste
schlaganfall zurückgekämpft hey hallo
okay allerdings dass ich drei leute noch
krank aber ja ich fand's sind ein
glücksfall dass ich die ausbildung
gemacht habe weil ich das gefühl habe
das hilft mir absolut die mama
bestmöglich zu unterstützen
wie wertvoll die pflege zuhause für alte
menschen ist weiß tatiana nur zu gut sie
hat schon in verschiedenen heimen
gearbeitet und ist heute für einen
privaten träger im einsatz dort ist sie
im betriebsrat und kennt die probleme
genau
wir sind so wenige wir sind so weniger
und das ist krass und daran geht eine
ganze reihe von kolleginnen zunehmend
kaputt zu hause kann tatjana ihrer
mutter das geben was neben der
körperlichen fege genauso wichtig ist
zuwendung
eigentlich gehört aber er dazu man lernt
auch so dass man genau deshalb auch
allen alten menschen einen
pflegebedürftigen so geben will
die sind einfach immer noch wunderschön
nahmen das machst so gollia
ich sage so
tatjana fliegt nicht nur ihre mutter
sondern auch ihre oma karin hausladen
umgebung sein können und das bedeutet
einmal schauen dass ich halt mit drüber
schauen dass ich da auf mich um die
tabletten command dass ich mich
zunehmend auch einfach um ihren alltag
mit kümmern
daher hat sie nur noch eine
teilzeitstelle mit 40 so geht es vielen
in der altenpflege vor allem auch wegen
der körperlichen belastung das beobachte
tatjana in ihrem beruflichen umfeld
60 prozent der kolleginnen in diesem
beruf arbeiten nur in teilzeit und
arbeiten dann auf einem level finanziell
was ich auf mindestlohn niveau bewegt es
ist ein desaster
bisher kann tatjana die pflege ihrer
mutter und ihrer oma neben ihrem beruf
stimmen sie genießt die zeit mit den
beiden so oft sie kann ich habe das
privileg dass das geht weil ich hier mit
wohnen kann weil das finanziell auch
funktioniert und ich hoffe dass es
natürlich so möglichst lange bleiben
kann also noch möglich also
weit über vier millionen
pflegebedürftige leben heute in
deutschland mehr als doppelt so viele
wie noch vor 20 jahren knapp die hälfte
kann nicht von angehörigen gepflegt
werden also die idee wieder unseren
beruf ist es die menschen in würde zu
begleiten es ist einfach wichtig wenn
das unser anspruch ist und er sollte es
unbedingt sein etwas wie einer
gesellschaft leben wir sonst dann müssen
wir mehr leute sein die sich um die
menschen kümmern als sonst müssen wir
genau daran sparen und das widerstrebt
uns allen denke ich die in den beruf
sind und diesen beruf ernsthaft
betreiben
[Musik]
drei starke frauen in mittelfranken und
tatjana sambale und ihrer mutter christa
sind bei uns aus dem heimischen
wohnzimmer
zugeschaltet ich freue mich ganz
besonders dass wir dabei sind eben auch
schon gerade ganz viele herzlichen
gekriegt übrigens von all den anderen
die dabei sind ich weiß nicht ob sie es
gesehen haben schon guten abend dann sie
beide
schon genannt wir haben ihren alltag
gesehen in dem sich ja dann doch
vieles man muss sagen glücklich fügt
allerdings nicht durch planung sondern
einfach durch glückliche zufälle darauf
kann man natürlich nicht bauen darauf
kann natürlich auch nicht jeder einfach
mal so bauen in deutschland was ist denn
ihre erwartung in ihrer konkreten
situation an die politik vor dieser
bundestagswahl
unsere erwartungen es ist ganz konkret
tief zu hinterfragen die pflege unserer
älteren unserer hilfebedürftigen unsere
kranken menschen tatsächlich in die
hände von pflege konzernen von
kapitalgesellschaften und von
investmentfonds geben wollen oder ob wir
uns wirklich mal die frage stellen
müssen warum haben wir ein
gesundheitssystem geschaffen was auf
profitmaximierung ausgerichtet ist ich
möchte an dieser stelle sagen das führt
dazu dass pflegekräfte land ausland als
kostenfaktoren diskreditiert werden dass
sie als kosten sagt von sich selber
wahrnehmen was ein furchtbarer zustand
ist und dass noch am besten fall im
schlimmsten fall kann der kolleginnen im
schichtwechsel die weinend zusammen
brechen den achten neunten oder zehnten
tag in folge und dann wieder hören dass
die 24 bewohner allein aus dem
wohnbereich sind das sind zustände da
fühlt man sich als verschleiß faktoren
dann wird man einfach nur als etwas
austauschbares wahrgenommen und es ist
etwas was mich wahnsinnig gemacht was
geändert werden muss was einfach nur
falsch ist und das hat mit der
konstituierung und mit dieser auf
profitmaximierung ausgeblieben ist zu
tun
verschleißt faktor
bevor
ich würde gerne recht gegeben das bietet
sich geradezu an den zuständigen
minister jens spahn
ersparen was was würden sie sagen darf
man mit pflege profit machen das war die
frage von georgiana sambale na ja auch
die caritas muss am ende schwarze zahlen
haben weil sie investieren muss weil die
rücklagen werden uns das entscheidende
ist und da hat frau sambale er
richtigerweise darauf hingewiesen
erstmal großen respekt das ist eine
ziemlich große lebensentscheidung zu
sagen ich mach einen großen teil meines
lebens jetzt eben auch für die pflege
der mutter in diesem fall und der
großmutter wenn ich es richtig gesehen
habe eine entscheidung die viele treffen
auch treffen müssen die meisten wären
übrigens zu hause gepflegt aber
jedenfalls zu dem punkt braucht am ende
natürlich auch ein pflegedienst egal ob
kommunal oder privat am ende schwarze
zahlen entscheidend ist welchen rahmen
setzen wir ja wir haben ja mittlerweile
gesetzlich geregelt sie können in der im
krankenhaus in der pflege zu lasten der
pflege nicht mehr sparen es ist kein
profit zu lasten der pflege mehr möglich
wir haben gerade geregelt wie
personalbemessung in der altenpflege ist
also für wie viele pflegebedürftige in
einer einrichtung mindestens dann auch
entsprechendes personal da sein muss
nach tarif zu bezahlen das dann auch
refinanziert wird auch dort ist
einsparen zu lasten der pflege dann
nicht mehr möglich und eins muss ich
bitte auch für werben ich weiß es wird
auf die konzerne geschaut das ist ein
relativ kleiner anteil in deutschland
die allermeisten privaten pflegedienste
in deutschland sind familiengeführte
kleine pflegedienst ambulant und
stationär die meisten übrigens von
frauen geführt ich wusste kaum ein
bereich in dem so viele frauen
gründerinnen sind wie in der pflege und
deswegen kann ich immer nur wieder dafür
werben ja die probleme auch dies bei
konzernen gibt und ich habe schon mal
gesagt zweistellige renditen in der
pflege ich kann mir gut vorstellen das
miteinander auch gesetzlich zu regeln da
müssen wir beim andersrum auch
sicherstellen dass die familiengeführten
pflegedienste schon auch eine chance
haben tatsächlich auch hinzu kommen
situation wie so schlimm in vielen
fällen gar nicht ist wir haben jetzt
aber ein ganz konkretes beispiel direkt
gesagt wir haben einfach leben ändert
sich jetzt noch ein satz zu sagen das
problem ist und da hätte ich auch eine
frage an frau sambale welche idee ich
noch mitnehmen kann wir haben
mittlerweile geregelt zusammenführung
der ausbildungsberufe bessere
perspektive ausbildungsvergütung 1000
euro mindestlohn in der pflege ab dem
ersten sieben tarif bezahlung ist kann
nicht mehr zu lasten der pflege gespart
werden wir haben festgelegt ist
verhältnis von pflegekräften zu
patienten und pflegebedürftigen wie
haben nur einen dingen das kann ich
nicht per gesetz regeln die stellen sind
finanziert das geld ist da jeder
pflegedienste in deutschland sucht
personal aber der arbeitsmarkt ist leer
gefegt und das ist nicht per gesetz mal
eben so zu ändern wir haben begonnen
eine spirale wieder in eine andere
richtung zu treten hin zu mehr
verlässlichkeit in der finanzierung aber
die wahrheit ist es geht nicht innerhalb
von monaten und wenn frau samt noch eine
idee hat wo wir noch die arenen können
hätte man dann frage herr sambale ich
mich lange jahre mitglied frage frau
startet natürlich gleich wir wollen
natürlich jetzt erstmal nicht unsere
gäste sozusagen die ideen in die sendung
einbringen lassen sondern die politiker
fragen welche ideen sie haben also
umgekehrt sozusagen vor gefallen sie
haben gehört wie die situation ist bei
den song bales zu hause jetzt regieren
sie ja mit dem bund was wie konnte es
oft so schief laufen es ist zunächst
einmal wir haben ja uns verbindet ja
entspannen und mich gemeinsam mit
hubertus heil dass wir in der legislatur
zusammen die konzertierte aktion pflege
startet haben ein ganz wichtiger punkt
der heute auch angesprochen worden ist
ist ja das personal der nachwuchs die
ausbildung von genügenden pflegekräften
die auch nach kommission bisher war so
dass man in deutschland schulgeld
bezahlen musste wenn man in die
ausbildung ging und keine
ausbildungsvergütung bekommen hat das
ist in dieser legislatur geändert worden
und ich glaube das ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt wir sehen ja auch erste
erfolge das in mehreren bundesländern
die ausbildungszahlen bis zu zehn
prozent teilweise sogar darüber
gesteigert werden konnten das ist ganz
enorm wichtig dass niemand sich in
deutschland mehr fragen muss kann ich es
mir eigentlich leisten pflegefachkraft
zu werden habe ich eine perspektive die
einführung der pflege studiengänge die
kommt führt zu einer situation wo junge
menschen auch sagen das ist für mich
attraktiver auch hier in berlin sind das
habe gerade mit jungen menschen die in
der generalistischen ausbildung sind
gesprochen die gesagt haben ohne die
ausbildungsvergütung hätte ich das
niemals machen können jetzt gibt es aber
viele die das tun und das ist eine
entwicklung dass es kein scheitern
aber es ist der richtige weg und
trotzdem muss man natürlich sehr sehr
ernst nehmen was ihr geschildert worden
ist dass nicht jede regelung die gemacht
wird sofort in der praxis ankommt dass
sie in der praxis was anderes erleben
und das auf den höfen extreme belastung
erleben das ist etwas da müssen wir uns
drum kümmern da kümmern wir uns auch
darum aber wenn man sich strukturell
fragt woher sollen die leute kommen dann
ist es wichtig dass sie ausgebildet
werden und dafür sind bessere
voraussetzungen geschaffen worden
[Applaus]
die dritte regierungsvertretung mit
reinnehmen hallo bringt was sagen sie
erstmal muss man feststellen es ist ein
problem das uns noch sehr lange
beschäftigen wird weil die zahlen derer
die zu pflegen sind die werden steigen
und mit dem steigen wird auch der bedarf
der pflege immer größer werden und wir
werden beides brauchen wir werden die
pflege in pflegeheimen brauchen wir
werden aber auch die private pflege
brauchen ich glaube wir müssen überlegen
ob wir die ausbalancierung an der stelle
zu gunsten auch der privaten pflege noch
mal deutlich stärken können wir haben
viel gemacht jetzt im bereich der pflege
stationären pflege in den heimen wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass der
tarifvertrag anwendung findet wir haben
dafür gesorgt dass die tarif bezahlung
funktioniert wird haben was in der
ausbildung gemacht ist alles richtig an
der stelle das gemacht worden ist aber
ich glaube wir werden auch deutlicher
dafür sorgen müssen dass eine pflege
zuhause gestärkt wird da geht es am
schluss dann auch über die beträge die
über die pflegekasse bezahlt werden auch
das ist ein dynamisches system das muss
stärker auf diesen fokus ausgerichtet
okay wir haben gehört was passiert ist
bevor wir zu den anderen parteien kommen
ganz kurz frau sonnenbaden noch wieder
mit reinnehmen
partie hier gehört haben ist da was
überzeugendes dabei aus ihrer sicht nein
also ich muss es ganz klar zu sagen es
ist schon seine oberfläche gekratzt
bestenfalls anderes kann man formulieren
es wird schon attraktiv verschleiert
also weder fresenius noch helios noch
andere große konzerne mit jahren
umsetzen sind die datenpflege
familienunternehmen von nebenan
gleichzeitig dieses stichwort
tarifvertrag hier an dieser stelle in
diesem kontext zu bringen verbindlich
für die pflege ist schon auch wirklich
im suff seine frechheit weil versucht
wurde seitens der gewerkschaften
nachzuarbeiten das qualitätsmerkmal ist
genau diese tarifverträge formuliert
werden dass eben unter grenzen
eingezogen werden da wurde sich dagegen
verwahrt auch nur einen einzigen satz
diesbezüglich noch mit aufzunehmen genau
diese spirale in der wir uns sehen seit
jahren dass wir in der praxis etwas
erleben das ist etwas versprochen wird
und dann nichts passiert und das ist für
uns in der debatte auf den stationen
schon irgendwann die frage in bezug auf
die verantwortlichen wo sind sie teil
potenzieller lösungen und wo definitiv
teil des problems okay da ist eine ganze
menge verbitterung ehrlich gesagt auch
zu hören er sagt es ist ja richtig aus
der opposition heraus schon mal mit
ihnen an was was werden sie da ändern
können als zunächst mal muss man diese
schilderung und man kann nur den hut
ganz ganz tief ziehen was frau sambale
leistet sowohl weiter in den beruf und
dann auch in ihrer familie
und wenn sie das schildert und ich nehme
das vollständig ab dann helfen wir
natürlich hinweise sehr sehr wenig
deswegen muss das eines der großen
reformvorhaben sein und das heißt
natürlich es werden viel mehr menschen
gepflegt werden dieser beruf muss viel
attraktiver werden natürlich muss er
auch besser bezahlt werden das ist doch
so dass viele auch heute noch aus diesen
berufen gehen warum gibt es kein
programm da gibt es ja einiges aber
warum sind immer noch viel zu wenige die
zurückgehen in den beruf also hier muss
in der nächsten legislaturperiode eine
weichenstellung vorgenommen werden da
müssen genau die vorschläge die
frühsommerliche gemacht hat die müssen
auch in der politik ankommen denn es
helfen keine stellschrauben 1 will ich
deutlich sagen also zu sagen
da müssen überall so dolle schwarze
zahlen herauskommen
das ist natürlich genau der punkt der
alles auf macht solange das
renditeobjekte auch sind und sie hat
einige konzerne genannt ist im gesamten
gesundheitswesen drauf solange es so ist
dass profit eine rolle spielt machen wir
einen riesenfehler gesundheit darf keine
ware sein ich möchte das immer
krankheit nach den symptomen und ich
dachte im geldbeutel behandelt werden
gemeinwohl und gewinne der rentner
sollte sind das ausschließen
nein das schließt sich ja in der praxis
nicht aus denn das was jens spahn gesagt
hat ist ja nun zutreffend das gros der
privaten pflegedienste sind kleine
mittelständische betriebe wie es
teilweise die solo selbstständige in der
stationären altenpflege in der
ambulanten altenpflege entschuldigung
und deshalb money sollten wir nicht mit
solchen feindbildern argumentieren
übrigens ist der pflege tarifvertrag
wenn ich es richtig sehe der neue
unlängst von der caritas abgesagt worden
also einem freigemeinnützigen trägern
nehmen wir doch das problem ernst
analysieren wo wirklich der schuh drückt
wir haben die situation dass viele
pflegende
einfach schlicht überfordert sind durch
das was an arbeitsverdichtung da ist die
stationen sind nicht voll besetzt weil
wir zu wenige menschen haben die dort
arbeiten und das ergebnis ist dass die
dort arbeiten in teilzeit job wechseln
weil sie es körperlich nicht schaffen
dann haben sie einkommen zu einbußen die
sie in kauf nehmen müssen weil sie
körperlich sonst den job nicht
durchstehen und das verweist für mich
auf den kern wir brauchen tatsächlich
mehr menschen die sich für diesen beruf
interessieren deshalb dietmar bartsch
sagen wir auch offen dass in den letzten
zehn jahren die bezahlung deutlich
verbessert worden ist richtig ist
richtig ist doch wie es richtig ist ja
wir können ja gucken was eine
pflegefachkraft verdient richtig ist
dass das schulgeld abgeschafft worden
ist es wird aber nicht reichen ich
glaube um die personal situation zu
entspannen damit auch mehr pflegen die
wieder vollzeit arbeiten wollen brauchen
wir erstens ein programm zur schnelleren
anerkennung ausländischer pflegekraft
die bei uns arbeiten wollen das
entspannt auch die situation dort am
arbeitsmarkt und nimmt druck von denen
die dort tätigen haben wir brauchen
lassen sie in die 1 punkte
will ich auch machen doch muss sie
müssen aber muss ich als du die menschen
wichtig ist über
500.000 haushalte haben stand jemanden
aus dem ausland der für sie arbeitet und
dort wird jetzt der mindestlohn auch
vorgesehen für die bereitschaftszeit das
sind über nachher modell des
arbeitsgebers sieht aber so ein
riesenproblem dass die politik lösen
muss ich habe noch keine lösung aber
500.000 haushalte sind die menschen in
sorge dass sie ihre jetzige
pflegesituationen selbst leben da die
die politik lösen muss haben wir glaube
ich hier wirklich zur genüge eine lange
und wir brauchen jetzt lösungen frau
beide in ihrem programm steht kinderlose
sollen selbst höhere rücklagen bilden
erklären sie uns doch bitte
also wir reden hier gerade über pflege
ja das problem um die pflege das genau
das problem was wir in deutschland haben
ist dass menschen pflegekräfte wie frau
sambale nicht gewertschätzt werden sie
haben eine schlechte bezahlung ist
funktioniert nicht und wir müssen die
pflegekräfte besser bezahlen und dazu
gehören beispielsweise auch steuerfreien
pauschalen auf sonnen feiertagen
und nach zuschläge steuerfrei zu stellen
und wir haben ja auch in diesem beispiel
gesehen viele menschen wollen zu hause
gepflegt werden 70 prozent der menschen
wollen zu hause gepflegt werden und
dementsprechend ist die pflege zu hause
mit der pflegestation er für die
pflegenden wird frau sambale
gleichzustellen diese menschen müssen
vernünftig bezahlt werden wo kommen wir
denn eigentlich dahin dass ich will nur
noch eine zahl sagen weil ja lindner
durfte ja auch extrem lang reden
eine zahl etwas zusagt durchschnittliche
durch
das höre ich jetzt gerne jagen sie ihre
zahl doch bitte kurz nur der
durchschnittliche lohn brutto von einer
pflegekraft in deutschland die ich bei
2.300 euro stimmen und da muss ich
wirklich sagen
wenig und sie müssen die leute
ordentlich bezahlen dann kriegen sie
auch genug leute 16 und 17
die nächtliche optisch zahl schnell
haben wir immer machen sie behaupten
irgendwas egal ob stimmt oder nicht
irgendeiner wird schon glauben das geht
doch so nicht es hat in frage
der vertrag lief im internet zdf
heute.de können wir alles ganz genau
checken das müssen wir nicht so stehen
lassen wir können aber frau
göring-eckardt auf jeden fall noch mit
rein ändern sie haben zu dieser runde
bisher noch nichts gesagt reden aber
weil sie sagte einer redet immer
besonders viel wir passen da schon sehr
genau auf und sie sind ganz vorne vor
gericht hat jetzt muss ich sie jetzt
bitte herzlich bitten kurz zu bleiben
glauben sie das problem pflege wird sich
in der nächsten zeit überhaupt lösen
lassen oder wird es eine weitere pflege
reform geben die den kern am ende wir
werden alle immer älter und wollen alle
würde voll gepflegt werden doch nicht
wirklich tangieren kann doch das müssen
wir lösen und wir brauchen dafür auch
garantien also einmal die bessere
bezahlung über die ist gesprochen worden
ja das sind etwas über 3.000 brutto wenn
man vollzeit arbeitet und wenn man es
schafft vollzeit zu arbeiten und wenn
man dafür sorgt dass man auch bei einem
arbeitgeber ist ja nicht dann noch
irgendwelche zusatzstunden verlangt das
passiert ja auch das zweite ist wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass leute nicht
angst haben davor alt und
pflegebedürftig zu werden und ich finde
da muss man eine garantie aussprechen
auch bei den zuzahlungen die häufig
gemacht werden müssen sie sollten wieder
bei den kindern landen noch sollten sie
das eigene bisschen ersparte auffressen
und da finde ich können wir wirklich was
dran ändern also gute bezahlung klarheit
und keine angst davor alt und
pflegebedürftig zu werden dass auch ihre
meine ansagen wir haben sehr viele
problembeschreibung gehört dass es
definitiv ein thema auch für die nächste
bundesregierung und sie haben
entscheidend dazu beigetragen dass es
noch mal ganz klar für uns geworden ist
familie sambale in mittelfranken ganz
ganz herzlichen dank dass sie heute bei
uns waren und ihr haus und ihr herz
geöffnet
nur unter dieser sendung ja klaus und
ihre herrchen von überall her
[Applaus]